est-ce que vous veniez jolie papy
bananière mois alors ouais ce qui les
unit papier ben bella boulogne
billancourt ils l'ont fait au pot dans
les nouveaux locaux de au pot est
aujourd'hui regarder de quoi on parle on
parle de ce smartphone alors ses écrits
ici le voyez bien c'est aux pauvres fine
day 'n' go find nfc hyper dur ailleurs
et en fait ça c'est le tout premier
smartphone pliable que présente au pot
alors il ya eu six générations prototype
pour arriver à ce modèle alors ce modèle
là je vous dis tout de suite soyons
clairs il ne sortira jamais en france
est-ce qu'on verra arriver aux pauvres
find n2 peut-être en france allez savoir
où tu sais pas en tout cas prêt à
regarder ses ailes et bien à quoi il
ressemble quelles sont les différences
par rapport à ses concurrents et on
pense notamment aux dans les smartphones
de samsung galaxy z folle de trois on va
voir à quel est le choix a fait ou pau
là dessus est ce qu'il est intéressant
ou pas mais la première chose est bien
c'est de se couvrir de regarder on sympa
[Musique]
regardez-moi ça attendez moi c'est
ouvrir comme sa hausse à cette année
comme c'est mignon ça alors ça c'est un
peu comme ça on le voit écrit si au
regard des récits et de vous le montrer
c'est pas hyper évident il est noté ici
designed for fine ce que vous le voyez
bien et la section chinois donc je ne
lis pas le chinois si vous lisez ce que
dit moi c'est écrit si on va en
commentaire alors on va se le prendre on
va se couvrir ça on va le regarder en
quelques instants qu'est-ce qu'on est
encore ici que je ne sais pas a tempêté
mais on a remonté des charges et à
peut-être je ne sais pas si on va avoir
un petit bloc de charge alors si c'est
de la recherche 33 watts on n'a pas de
la charge 65 watts ou plus si affinités
pour en prendre deux places en fait à
l'intérieur du smartphone mais bon 33
votes pourquoi pas vous le recharger en
fait de 0 à 100% en 70 minutes il faut
quand même ça met un peu de patience
vous avez une marque de 4500 millions
terreur à l'intérieur mais on va se
regarder ça qu'est ce qu'on a ici le
coup xtended la carte de garantie et
puis oui je vous dis une fois plus les
chinois allaient compass ça on laisse de
côté regardons maintenant ce qu'on a eu
c'est surtout ça qui nous intéresse
alors il a déjà été un boxer là c'est
une nouvelle boxing parce qu'il tourne
forcément entre différents médias le
regarder ça là c'est quand même pas mal
pour trouve vraiment le design du
finepix trois pros sur la partie arrière
le grand écran ici on va regarder les
specs dans quelques instants alors le
format est vachement intéressant parce
que beaucoup plus petit que de ce qu'on
a pu voir aujourd'hui hiver par rapport
au samsung galaxy z folle de trois ans
sert notre forme ainsi on va comparer
par rapport aux et flip 3 on est
vraiment dans toute chose ça reprend
vraiment l'essence du z folle de 3 le
format un petit peu livre dans les temps
beaucoup plus petit a regardé je vous en
un êtes folle de 3 cm en pas la même
chose à la taille et les énormes
différences il est un peu plus large
l'épaisseur c'est sensiblement la même
chose mais la hauteur ça n'a strictement
rien à voir alors fait de voir ce petit
truc là comment on vient là lui mais
alors si ces colorants s12 basé sur un
android de 11 il faut savoir que les
applis sont pas adaptés un smartphone
qui se plie c'est la raison pour
laquelle est bien priori ne sortira
qu'en chine parce qu'on n'a pas vraiment
d'appli complètement adaptée alors vers
un travail qui va être fait en
partenariat avec google pour réussir à
emmener une expérience beaucoup plus
intéressante au niveau du pliable sur un
android et puis bien évidemment avec
différents développeurs alors déjà à ce
qu'on voit la différence qu'on a avec le
samsung galaxy cette folle de traces qui
si on n'a pas de caméras planquées sous
l'écran bondir c'est du pain de détail
et le voir là un écran extérieur ici
voilà on a vraiment retrouvé à l'idée de
s'ouvrir comme un livre vous le prenez
vous l'ouvrez vous avez ici un grand
écran intérieur cdu amoled 7,1 pouces
1792 par 1920 pixels surtout le ratio
qui est un peu différent séduit 8,4 9e
c'est très particulier a effectivement
on est tout le temps en format paysage
c'est vraiment ce qu'a voulu venir faire
au pot là dessus attendez hop là je vous
emmène dans les paramètres pour qu'on se
rende un petit peu mieux compte c'est
pas mal c'est assez intéressant quand
même comme format de l'avoir directement
comme ça ça fait vraiment mal c'est pas
un format carré on est sur l'espèce de
foccart et on voit qu'il est quand même
un poil plus long ici à l'intérieur
j'avais un taux de rafraîchissement qui
va être dynamique de 1 à 120 hertz alors
ici on nous annonce jusqu'à 200 milles
pliage sens absolument aucun problème ok
why not alors qu'avec un truc qui est
vraiment vraiment vraiment intéressant
c'est qu'en fait lorsque vous replier et
bien vous avez absolument aucun jour ici
à la différence et je reprends une fois
de plus mon galaxy z folle de trois
voyages un petit jour on le voit ici
l'artiste de ville et là ils ont
vraiment un système de charnières qui
complètement différent est ce qui vous
permet de le refermer complètement alors
c'est vraiment pas mal il ya un côté un
peu je sais pas si c'est plus rassurant
ou pas mais je trouve ça assez efficace
ça fonctionne bien alors point de vue
design qu'est-ce qu'on retrouve sur le
côté un capteur d'empreintes digitales
sur la tranche le bouton de volume de
quoi leurs charges et si on us baissé on
a des haut parleurs stéréo dolby atmos à
l'extérieur on a un écran amoled de 5,49
pouces avec un ratio 18/9 60 hertz ici
et une résolution de 1972 par 988 pixels
alors ici par contre vous allez avoir un
corps nu gorilla glass victime ce que
vous n'avez pas l'intérieur forcément ça
veut dire protéger votre écran extérieur
votre écran intérieur vous allez faire
attention lorsqu'il est ouvert on va pas
jeter partout en tout temps ce qui est
intéressant c'est qu'on nous annonce une
luminosité maximale jusqu'à 1000 dit ce
que vous soyez à l'intérieur ou à
l'extérieur et un taux d'échantillonnage
tactile 2009 uniquement à l'intérieur
pour venir jouer à plein de jeux on
trouve ça assez intéressant tout en
sachant que soit votre écran intérieur
vous allez à peu près la même techno
peuvent être même la même techno avoir
trouvé dans le smartphone pliable de
samsung c'est à dire avec une mince
couche de verre pour augmenter la
résistance du produit alors il ya la
question du poids est importante ici on
fait quoi 275 grammes c'est un poil plus
lourd que le z folle de trois maintenant
un truc qui est intéressant avec un
format comme celui là c'est que vous le
mettez dans la poche assez facilement
mais je veux mais là alors il est quand
même un peu épais donc on va le voir
mais on s'y attendre a forcément on
prend un smartphone dont le pli on a un
peu d'épaisseur que je trouve vraiment
intéressant sur ce produit c'est ce
format qui est vraiment différent par
rapport une fois de plus au galaxy s est
folle de troie qui va être fatalement
lui plus grand donc c'est pas facile et
manipuler comme ça donc c'est assez
marrant fait varier le format est
complètement différent là pour la voir
en format paysage des trolls de troy il
faut le tourner là vous l'avez
directement en format paysage l'effet de
la voir dans la main garder fermées dans
des patients truc qui est hyper grand
lorsqu'il vous comparez par rapport à un
iphone 13 pro mac ce qui est quand même
énorme bronca y ait une vraie vraie
différence il ya un choix qui a été fait
qu'un vrai parti pris là dessus par
oprah que je trouve vraiment intéressant
pour le coût en termes de performances
on a retrouvé ce qu'il y à mieux voir
quasiment ce qui est mieux on est sur un
dragon 888 alors ici on n'est pas sera
sa dragonne 8 génial parce que moment où
il a été officialisé et bien le genoa
n'avait pas encore été lancé néanmoins
en termes de performances il ya vraiment
ce qu'il faut sous le capot on a soit 8
soit 12 ian ramenant l p ddr5 qui on va
avoir 256 ou 512 giga de stockage en
effet ces trois points autant vous dire
que ya ce qu'il faut ça va tartiner on a
une grosse batterie à l'intérieur de
quatre mille cinq cents millions terreur
de la recharge superbook 33 watts en
filaire on a de la recherche 15 watts
sans fil et on aide la recharge inversée
et si je dis pas de bêtises à l'aide de
l'adie watts est ce que c'est ça david
c'est la diaw est inversé tu sais ou pas
ça doit être ça puisqu'on est sur un
smartphone en outre en à l'appareil
photo le regarder à l'arrière vous avez
un triple module photo on va voir en
grande pompe de 50 méga pixels ce qui
n'est pas le cas tu me lis mais lui
ouvre à f 1.8 on va avoir une ultra
grand-angle de 16 mégapixels équivalent
14 mm ouvrez 2.2 et puis un 13
mégapixels dernier on se rapproche la au
regard d'un 13 mégapixels pour un tel
objectif à zoom optique x 2 équivalent
50 2008 tous rêvent de pau 4 il vous
avez sur l'écran externe lagarde est
juste là là mais également à l'intérieur
plantier justice'' caméra de selphy 30 2
mégapixels que vos rêves deux points car
c'est un smartphone forcément qui
vendent la 5g bah oui on est un dragon
888 ici et qui annonce est résistant à
la poussière mais pour autant on n'a pas
de certification ip68 donc là on est
avec david chevaux que les chefs de
produits smartphones chez au pot ça va
david rien ce trésor à chaque fois qu on
se voit on appelle jolie nouveauté à
regarder ensemble find and quelques
briques sur la toile il y en a plusieurs
gros chat c'est là leur coloris rota
lequel toi j'ai le blanc blanc qui est
un peuple en céramique ouais donc là ça
c'est le boulot en céramique et il
existe également doit exister entre
également en noir avec finition mate
donc anti traces de doigts un qui est un
petit peu plus stable et plus beaux
alors moi je suis embêté il sortirait
jamais au fond se produit alors passé
lucide mais il y en aura d'autres la
bonne nouvelle c'est que le produit est
prêt techniquement et technologiquement
donc maintenant on peut espérer que ça
arrive rapidement en europe après
effectivement celui-ci était pas prévu
pour le marché européen est encore un
travail à faire notamment au niveau de
la collaboration avec les applications
tierces pour pouvoir adapter les
applications les plus utilisées ici à ce
smartphone arias déjà des applications
qui fonctionnent très bien un parent
plan je savais que j'ai fait plusieurs
tests de jeux ça fonctionne très bien ça
fait quand même un super écran un tout
mais sur certaines applications
youtube par exemple c'est pas forcément
encore totalement de s'alléger donc
voilà il ya parce que le form factor est
un petit peu différent par rapport à
d'autres clients qu'on peut avoir sur le
sur le marché aux classes si je meurs
youtube ça fonctionne pas tu me dis je
pense pas que ça fonctionne pas mais
c'est que le ca pour être plus optimisés
en termes de d'écran d'une vidéo là pour
l'instant en fait quand je mets une
vidéo je vais avoir la vidéo en fait qui
va paraître sur la gauche et puis le
menu déroulant donc c'est une manière de
faire parce qu'il serait plus sympa
c'est d'avoir évidemment la vidéo au
dessus tu peux pas le pas soit pas
l'écran si on peut évidemment si je le
passe sans qu'un écran après on passe en
mode paysage mais ça fonctionne ça va
plus ça fonctionne mais ça pourrait être
encore avec sa boîte plutôt timide
d'accord ok donc là ça veut dire que
vous êtes prêt à voir des smartphones
pliable chez aux pauvres on le voit avec
ce produit là pour l'instant pas encore
prêt pour l'europe et le reste du monde
quand ils sortent en chine celui là
c'est ça oui on peut espérer peut-être à
la fois de l'année de l'année prochaine
voir arriver à une opération n'a pas
d'infos pour l'instant que j'espère mais
on n'a pas d'info mais j'espère aussi
que ça arrivera rochelle si ce produit
là devait sortir en europe ça serait
quoi son prix parce que là il annonça
qui est un beau challenge en chine il
est à peu près 1000 1100 euros et 1300
euros pour la version un peu plus boosté
de mémoire ok donc ce qui fréquente en
france il sera peu près mille trois cent
mille 500 selon la configuration même
d'accord ok là il ya un parti pris qui
est vraiment différent par rapport à ce
qu'on peut retrouver à la concurrence le
fait d'avoir un smartphone qui est un
peu plus petit donc forcément plus
facile à prendre en main pourquoi avoir
fait ce choix que tu as des infos sur le
choix du form factors positionner comme
ça de proposer quelque chose qui est
encore différent par rapport à ce qui
existe sur le marché oui mais enfin topo
est pas à sa première version il ya eu
déjà six prototypes en quatre ans qui
ont été travaillés effectivement s'est
posé la question à plusieurs reprises
avec différents formats qu'est-ce qui
était l'option la plus adaptée et
finalement c'est sur celle ci qu'on a
choisi parce que la fête quand le
smartphone est plié on est sur un petit
format qui est facile à prendre à une
main c'est vrai même si effectivement il
a un petit pois ont quand même ça c'est
un client mais voilà c'est un format de
5 à 40 9 pouces et le format est aussi
complètement adapté à la au monde
android parce qu'on est sur un écran qui
et qui est accessible partout qui est
pas trop long et une fois que c'est
ouvert l'avantagent aussi c'est qu'on a
un format qui finalement presque un
petit peu car est ce qui fait que c'est
comme si j'avais deux écrans de
smartphones standard avec un an tandis
je prends la firefox je peut diviser
l'écran de ici et avoir deux aptes et
sont l'une à côté de l'autre et l'autre
avantage aussi c'est du coup avec le
format paysage finalement gelée
directement quand je lui suis pas besoin
de le retourner après sur le côté pour
regarder un film par exemple aux autres
mais côté c'est tout bête mais c'est un
parti pris aussi tu fais référence à une
marque concurrente
sans faire de référence c'est beau la
simple c'est un parti pris ok donc voilà
après l'autre point important
effectivement c'était une partie majeure
du travail au pot sur la recherche de ce
produit c'est vraiment s'il a rayé à
l'absence de figure elle est visible
légèrement mais elle est quand même
nettement moins visibles par rapport à
ce qui a fait de proposer ça c'est un
truc qui est extrêmement surprenant
c'est à dire que quand on prend un
smartphone pliable et bien en dehors de
votre on sent quand même un peu la pluie
rend là sont sous le doigt il ya des
générations qui avance en sont un peu
moins mais là déjà cela voit quasiment
pas vraiment et puis surtout je sens
quand quasiment rien mais quasiment rien
sous le doigt si je le sens c'est parce
que vraiment je me force à me dire ok ce
qui ne lui font de la recherche mais
sinon c'est c'est extrêmement bluffant
comment ça se fait il ya eu un travail
technologie qui permet d'éviter cette
sensation de clients web il ya plus de
136 composants dans la charnière donc
c'est vraiment une charnière aussi qui
en fait fonctionne un peu comme une
petite goutte d'eau ouais ce qui permet
que ça permet de pas plié de manière
trop dure en fait l'écran et c'est aussi
ça qui permet d'avoir un d'éviter cette
plus en fait c'est pour ça aussi que
quand il est pliée s'il n'y a pas un
espace du haut vers le bas alors que sur
d'autres modèles on va voir comme un peu
cet effet là un peu triangle ouais c'est
pas le cas ici donc c'est vraiment c'est
la technologie la charnière qui fait
qu'on arrive à éviter d'avoir cette donc
la cw les fils et lui dire qu'en plus il
est complètement plié et en plus je ne
sens rien sous droits et ces tests et
pour partir en allemagne pour 200 milles
plus sûrs sans compromis sur justement
le ya quoi faire inclure sa vie n'est
qu'hier que faire le mouton magnétique
d'astuces d'uzège par exemple qu'on va
avoir quoi et si la wii alors sur
l'appareil photo ce qui est sympathique
c'est que du coup bas le fait de
m'initier un grand écran à pouvoir par
exemple avoir un aperçu de ces photos
prises à cagots chez lui continue de
faire de la capture à droite j'ai aussi
à voir ici une petite option qui me
permet en fait d'avoir l'aperçu
également sur l'écran qui est derrière
ok pour la personne que je prends en
photo comme ça et voilà aussi ce que ce
que je prends ça permet aussi du coût de
2 voire effectivement si je vais
utiliser le capteur arrière qui sera le
forcément de meilleurs qualité alors
juste parce que j'ai fait j'ai encore
fait l'équipe modèle dit ça c'est le
syndrome de la démo pas là donc là ça
marche donc l'âme à l'âge peut voir à
l'espace que j'appuie en fait sur les
boutons d'accord ok aussi ce qui est
sympa vu que ça peut servir
effectivement presque comme comme d'un
trépied comme pour le téléphone puisque
je peux le mettre comme ça pour les
thèmes l'aps est plutôt sympa alors on a
augmenté un petit peu les options on a
ici des options avec laquelle il eut le
ciel étoilé etc mavenir déterminé par un
minuteur le nombre de temps qu'on veut
faire le time lapse la vitesse etc et
pas mal de petites options qui était
proposée justement pour recruter tout le
potentiel cas le produit via son
fondateur au terme de multitâche comment
ça fonctionne du coût en terme de du
multitâche évidemment c'est plutôt sympa
aussi puisque je peut scinder l'écran
directement avec seulement deux doigts
et donc avoir finalement deux
applications ouvertes en même temps je
peux aussi tout à fait par exemple
transformer une fenêtre comme sans
fenêtre flottante la déplacer et faire
d'autres choses en même temps voire même
la caisse est temporairement sera elle
apparaîtra ici je peux la retrouver à
n'importe quel moment je peux faire
autre chose en attendant quand je tape
un message aussi j'ai un clavier qui est
adapté et scinder en deux en fait pour
on va taper des deux côtés fascinant
avec le pouce je peux faire revenir mon
application aussi ici et après
évidemment forcément ce format est
plutôt intéressant aussi pour tout ce
qui est jeu parce que j'ai pour pouvoir
profiter vraiment d'un écran à ces
assises merci sachant qu'on est vraiment
aussi en plus sur des écrans 120 hertz
avec un taux d'échantillonnage mille
1000 r donc on a vraiment quelque chose
de très réactif et très dynamique pour
le voilà pour cette découverte prise en
main unboxing duo peau fine n alors
c'est très sympa j'adore ce produit je
trouve très intéressant il ya très très
beau travail qui a été fait au niveau de
l'écran intérieure elle fait surtout de
ne pas sentir du tout de rien ici on
sent rien c'est ça c'est vachement bien
j'aime beaucoup le format je trouve très
intéressant ça serait à tester sur lui
plus longtemps pour pouvoir se rendre
compte aux ça c'est un peu frustrant
parce que ce smartphone il va repartir
il va être représentée à d'autres médias
donc ça c'est vachement bien mais par
contre je pourrais pas le revoir je
pourrais pas leur testé je pourrais pas
vous dire ce que j'en pense sur le long
terme donc c'est une très jolie
découverte permet de voir effectivement
et bien le travail d'innovation que fait
au pot ici avec ce find and on attend de
voir ce qui va arriver avec la série
find x 4 qui devrait pas tarder à priori
pas voir le jour je posais la question
mais je sais que personne ne répondra
ici donc on verra ça enverrait les
innovations à voir ce qui arrive en tout
cas sûre ça vachement bien le travail
qu'a fait au pot et si puis j'ai hâte de
voir ce qui va arriver dans les temps à
venir et de pouvoir enfin avoir sur le
marché français un smartphone qui se
plie fabriquée par opel donc ça c'est
cool et moi ce que vous en pensez vous
rendre en commentaire comment vous le
trouvez ce aux profanes n le nom est
très compliqué fine line s'est passé
c'est compliqué à dire à prononcer est
ce que vous aimez bien la proposition
dopo par rapport à celle de samsung pour
notamment par rapport aux est folle de 3
est ce que vous trouvez ce format plus
intéressant moins intéressant est ce
qu'ils peuvent ou tenter ce que vous
pourriez vous laisser tenter bien
évidemment s'il arrivait en france moi
tout ça un en bas dans les commentaires
et puis nous on se retrouve très vite
pour continuer à parler d'elle parce que
ça c'est vachement bien vous embrasse à
bientôt au tchad
[Musique]